the LCS has been suspended for two weeks
the 2023 summer split was due to begin
tomorrow but after players agreed to
Stage a walkout in protest of riots
changing of North America's tier 2
system the league is off for the
foreseeable future there's a whole lot
to know if you want to understand just
how we got to this historic moment in
Esports
[Music]
every split Riot gives a start date for
the LCS and every split the LCS starts
on that date but not this time so how
did we get here well it all started a
few weeks ago when Riot announced some
major changes to the n a challenger
system also known as the NaCl the system
has its roots in the 2018 franchising of
the LCS before that teams could be
promoted from the tier 2 North America
Challenger Series into the LCS or
demoted back down to it franchising
changed all of that though orgs bought
spots in the LCS and could no longer be
demoted from it after franchising the
Challenger Series was rebranded to the
na Academy League featuring Academy
squads of the LCS teams these teams will
compete against each other in a regular
league and beginning last year against
amateur teams in The Proving Grounds
tournament the system was intended to
create a healthy tier 2 scene in North
America that promoted talent development
and gave more players a legitimate path
to the pro level then in November 20 22
Riot replaced this structure with the
North American Challengers League which
would feature a mix of fixed franchised
Academy teams who would be immune to
relegation and provisional formerly
amateur teams who could lose their spots
to teams from open qualifiers if they
performed poorly enough but everything
changed just a few weeks ago on May 12th
of this year Riot announced that after
requests from LCS teams they had agreed
to remove the mandate to field an
academy team in an effort to quote
unlock more operational and financial
flexibility the NaCl was also to change
to a one-way promotion and relegation
system where teams could drop out of the
NaCl but would be unable to promote to
the LCS essentially LCS teams felt the
academy system was no longer cost
effective or fit for purpose or both and
Riot agreed now this is the part in the
story where the LCS Players Association
comes in I spoke to Philip Aram their
executive director who explained to me
the organization's Origins and purpose
The Players Association was founded at
the outset of franchising actually
originally by Riot games in
collaboration with players in an effort
to balance the scales of what
franchising does to player rights we
operate as a lobbying body in many ways
that's how we think of ourselves we
gather
and build support from our membership
around the issues that matter to them
and then we go and we are their voice
and eyes and ears in their room to help
Advocate to get those positions to be
made now for the most part they've had a
fairly amicable relationship with Riot
when trying to find a compromise between
the new policies they want to implement
and what's best for the players but this
recent change crossed a line for them
the Players Association put out a
statement saying the latest changes
would destroy the NaCl and see up to 70
players coaches and managers lose their
jobs overnight they said the decision to
remove the Mandate contradicted previous
Riot statements made to them and called
on everyone in the LCS and NaCl
Community to demand a reversal from Riot
they stated more than half of current
LCS Pros came up through the NaCl system
and it not only supports homegrown
talent but creates Financial savings for
orgs they directly called out the claim
that the NaCl creates Financial
instability by stating that the average
annual salary cost of an NaCl roster
represents less than 17 percent of an
average orgs League based salary costs
while many in the community sympathize
with those comments from the Players
Association it seemed that many of the
orgs did not over the next week NaCl
team started dropping like flies over
the next six days Cloud9 NRG dignitas
and golden Guardians all announced they
would no longer be Fielding an academy
team in the NaCl although they'd not
made a public announcement The Players
Association also added Immortals and TSM
to that list Team Liquid EG and flyquest
were in the minority when announcing
they would continue to field NaCl teams
but all three share concerns that the
NaCl in its current format is not
fulfilling its core role as a
sustainable path to the pro level for
players and teams The Players
Association called out the seven orgs
who would be dropping their NaCl teams
for not being able to spend the
estimated 15 to 20 percent of the 3
million given to them by Riot to fund
their tier 2 rosters our stance is that
this is table stakes and for any team to
come and say we cannot afford to operate
in the NaCl a place that we know is not
an expensive place to operate or we know
not all teams are operating at maximum
efficiency to begin with to say that we
can't afford to operate if you make us
be here we think is a something where
Riot needs should not have one should
not have taken a bait they should say
well we're giving you plenty of money we
know that you have enough funds from us
alone to operate in both of these spaces
and you need to make better financial
decisions rather than come to us and ask
for bailout the finger-pointing within
the community began some blame the LCS
orgs others said that Riot facilitated
all of this but Philip told me that
although he doesn't agree with the
position of all these LCS teams there's
a deeper issue at the core of this what
really comes down to here is the fact
that we were excluded you know our seat
at the table was you know effectively
revoked we were ignored and misled uh in
the lead up
um you know we did not believe that
there was any any consideration of a
change happening this year that only
next year was was on the table in
discussion and that that conversation
was going to be ongoing one for months
ahead uh so to have the rug pulled on us
uh you know both I think spoke to a lack
of you know lack of respect for the
Player's voice and and their importance
at the table and and having a seat there
and it also had Direct harm to a lot of
people you know we've been dealing with
the aftermath of this decision and the
fact that it lacked there was a lack of
a plan or Preparation
um it truly was a rug pull and something
very sudden and our players felt the
brunt of that on May 23rd journalist
Mikhail Mentor reported that LCS players
would be holding a vote on whether to
Stage a walkout in protest against the
changes this was made all the more
pressing by the fact that the LCS was
due to start in a little over a week on
June 1st and at least on paper no
players meant no LCS The Players
Association outlined their requests of
Riot to avert a walkout including
promotion and relegation between the LCS
and NaCl committing three hundred
thousand dollars to NaCl teams every
year allowing LCS Orcs to partner with
Affiliates for cost sharing guaranteeing
LCS minimum contracts for the following
year for the fire players that win LCS
summer and instituting a three-fifth
roster continuity rule to allow released
NaCl rosters first priority in
maintaining their slots if a team's
majority continue to compete together
the community waited with baited breath
to see if an 11th Hour deal could be
struck between the two parties but Riot
did not agree with the requests of them
on May 20 a specific time the Players
Association announced the vote had
overwhelmingly passed they criticized
Riot's lack of communication over their
decision making and called upon them to
avert the war count by having an open
and transparent discussion on the best
futures for the LCS and NaCl this action
players calling for a walkout and
agreeing to do a walkout is a testament
to our desire for Riot to see sense and
come in and meet with us and find real
solutions we're not here to you know we
care about playing our players care
about being a part of this league and
competing for championships that's the
last thing they want to do is walk out
but while support poured in from the
community for these players that were
seen to be standing up for themselves
Riot didn't budge on Monday a report
from journalist sander Hove known as LCS
EV on Twitter stated that Riot had
granted teams permission to sign
additional players post roster lock and
later that night Travis Gafford would
report the level to win LCS player
requirements had been dropped by Ryan I
don't think this news has broken yet but
I've heard from multiple sources within
an hour of the show starting that Elsa
that Riot is officially suspending the
requirements to play in the LCS so now
you can be of any rank
and you can play from anywhere you can
play from home even that's right this
was Ryan's attempt to circumvent the war
count by allowing LCS teams who are
contractually obliged to field a team to
temporarily use any player of any rank
they could even play remotely that meant
that technically any of you watching
this suddenly became eligible to play in
the LCS but don't get too excited if you
know anything about strikes and labor
disputes you know that any workers in
this case the players who choose to
cross that picket line and fill those
empty spots are known as scabs the
somewhat derogatory term is used to
criticize people who are seen to be
undermining the effectiveness of a
strike and the bargaining power of a
union in this case the Players
Association and they responded by
calling on players to not agree to play
for any LCS org as a replacement player
stating the walkout is for the benefit
of all n a players and the crossing the
picket line puts all players Futures at
risk and undermines their negotiating
power they said there was only one
solution to meet with the players and
agree to a plan that everyone can
support if the battle lines weren't
already drawn they certainly were now
riots seemed determined to forge ahead
with the planned LCS start date despite
the fact that over half of the pro
players were used to seeing playing
every week could be replaced by random
names or even LCS org staff members
there were even reports of LCS Orcs
approaching college teams in the hopes
of filling the empty slots with some
Team Heads making it clear they would
not be obliging with those requests just
yesterday Hunter cook of sports Business
Journal reported that the Players
Association had another meeting with
riots and just after that Riot finally
spoke out but it was not the walking
back that some had hoped for far from it
in fact the article by global head of
League Esports Nars alataha started with
Riot proclaiming their support for the
LCS and everyone who works in it they
expressed their desire to build a
sustainable economically viable
predictable League that supports a
thriving ecosystem around it they
described how they want to create a
similar tier to ecosystem in North
America as seen in the other major
regions of Europe China and Korea they
announced they will be giving the nacl's
tournament operator rallycry a further
three hundred thousand dollars to
operate the league in addition to their
previously announced Revenue Share Plans
but while this may sound somewhat
conciliatory there was an incoming
bombshell Riot conceded that their plan
of removing player restrictions for LCS
teams would not hold true to their
values and desires to showcase the best
competitive League of Legends and had
informed The Players Association that
they would be delaying the LCS season
for the next two weeks they noted that
they hope this two-week period will give
everyone at the table time for
productive dialogue but if the promise
of time and open dialogue was the carrot
next came the stick Riot declared that
any delay beyond the two weeks would
make it nearly impossible to run a
legitimate competition and they will be
prepared to cancel the entire LCS summer
season they said if this were to happen
LCS teams would also be eliminated from
qualifying for world 2023. the rest of
the article was dedicated to responding
to the requests from The Players
Association in a nutshell they said the
valorant style promotion and relegation
model would be unfair to the LCS teams
who paid 10 million for their league
spot that expanding the pool of teams by
allowing promotion to the LCS would
dilute the 50 Revenue that current LCS
orgs receive now the 300K Revenue pool
for NaCl player salaries is
unsustainable and unnecessary and that
they already allow LCS orgs to partner
with Affiliates and it's not just Riot
who are picking holes with these
requests some in the community aren't
entirely convinced that what the Players
Association is asking for is fair even
calling the request ridiculous or in the
case of tyler1 calling out entire
walkout so if you're not taking players
from Academy anyway you might as well to
stop paying for it so I feel like people
are striking and people are upset bro
what was it even doing anyway like I
said there's people crying about it well
no in a pro if we're being honest
there's not any it hasn't been any
talent in Years anyway why are we just
now mad about it because oh there's no
innate Talent so now now finally we're
just gonna stop bleeding money we're not
gonna write whatever and it's on anyway
and we're just gonna cancel the teams
but people are like well no we need the
teams to have him and they Talent there
is nobody nobody was getting promoted
anyway so with the LCS summer 2023 split
delayed for at least the next two weeks
now the situation is well it's kind of
LCS orgs they're players their staff
their fans and now faced with the
prospect of North America not being
present at Worlds if the two parties
can't come to an agreement in the next
two weeks that is mind-blowing when it
was founded the Players Association was
seen by some as little more than a token
gesture of power sharing from riots but
since their complete separation from
them in 2020 they've held Riot's feet to
the fire over player rights and their
involvement in LCS policy changes
there's a real sense of precedent here
that this is perhaps the first example
we've seen of collective action in
Esports but for Philip this is just all
about the players people talked about
the president side so yeah you know
we've done a lot of things but there's
still a lot more to do so I'm less
concerned with precedent today than just
doing the work that our players need to
um you know to get back to work and feel
comfortable in their jobs and in their
Futures uh you know fixing the harm done
is is first and foremost my mind and
less so the
um what this means elsewhere if you
think you know where this is going I
think you could be talking bollocks this
has had more twists than a TV show and
it's still all up in the air one thing
we know though is that it's not over
this two-week window has simply pushed
the standoff further down the road
either the players and their Association
will Buckle or after weeks of doubling
down Riot will pull one of the biggest
returns we've ever seen whatever happens
next I'll see you back here very soon
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock